hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem appeared in a uk maths
competition
simplify and give your answer as an
integer for the following fraction
the numerator is the product of five
terms
the first term is ten factorial plus
nine factorial the second term is eight
factorial plus seven factorial the third
term is six factorial plus five
factorial
the fourth term is four factorial plus
three factorial and the final term is 2
factorial plus 1 factorial
the denominator
is the same terms except each pair
is a subtraction
so it starts out with 10 factorial minus
9 factorial and it ends with 2 factorial
minus 1 factorial
if you're up for a challenge i thought
it would be fun to extend this pattern
all the way until the largest number is
100 factorial
can you figure it out
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
for positive number
n factorial is equal to the product of
the whole numbers going from 1 to n
the factorial is a recursive function in
the sense
that the
product of the numbers from 1 to n minus
1 is equal to n minus 1 factorial
so we can also write that n factorial is
equal to n
times n minus 1
factorial this will be a useful form
that we can use to simplify
the problem
a general term in the numerator
is n factorial plus n minus 1 factorial
we'll rewrite n factorial in terms of
its recursive form
and now we have n minus 1 factorial
being common to both terms
so we can factor out n minus 1 factorial
to get that n factorial plus n minus 1
factorial is equal to n minus 1
factorial times the quantity n plus 1.
a general term in the denominator is n
factorial minus n minus 1 factorial
we can use the same approach and
simplify this
to the form where we have n minus 1
factorial times the quantity n minus 1.
so let's use these formulas to simplify
this fraction
we'll look at the first term in the
numerator and denominator
10 factorial plus 9 factorial can be
simplified using the formula for the sum
and 10 factorial minus 9 factorial can
be simplified using the formula for the
difference
the numerator becomes 9 factorial times
11 and the denominator becomes 9
factorial times 9.
we can simplify the next term in this
fraction similarly
we end up with the numerator being 7
factorial times 9 and the denominator
being 7 factorial times 7.
let's use these formulas and simplify
all the other terms in this fraction
we end up with a series of products of
factorials
and odd numbers
there's going to be a lot of
cancellation going on so let me just
focus on the factorials so that we can
make it very clear
in the numerator i'll bring all the
factorials to the left hand side and the
same thing i'll do in the denominator
now you can very clearly see
in our fraction
that all of these factorials will cancel
out
for the product of the odd numbers
we have almost all of them canceling out
except we have one odd number of 11
remaining in the numerator and the odd
number of one remaining in the
denominator
so this all simplifies to be exactly 11.
now for the challenge problem where you
go up to 100 factorial i'm not going to
go through every single detail
you can follow the same steps and use
this approach of cancellation to get
that the answer will be one hundred
plus one which is one hundred and one
did you figure out these problems
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshellwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description